the truth is they just don't want us to
be able to vote that way no they they
don't want more turnout the reason they
do Jerry mandering the reason they
schedule elections and dates that are
hard to vote out of it restrict access
is they want to control the electorate
and they especially don't want gen Z and
gen Alpha when they come up each voting
because they're going to be held
accountable for all kinds of problems
that they've let fester and and let get
out of control so if you want to make
things better it has to be in the
interest of that politician to do so and
then we did Uber the same people who
don't know who their state senator is
they never vote in a city council
primary were taking the time to advocate
for us because a it was something they
cared about and B we made it really easy
right you could do it right from the app
and so when that happened and we're
thinking like holy if people could
vote this way maybe turn out would be a
lot higher and so if we want things to
get done we have to sort of get more and
more people voting and the only election
that really matters is the primary
because of Jerry mandering and the only
way I think to increase primary turnout
at scale to let people do it securely on
their phones